okay so here is our big moment and I
have a confession to make I have
lectured about this movie before I love
the movie I've seen it just for my own
enjoyment probably as five times and
I've watched selected clips from this
movie dozens and I was going over just
to look at the turning points on the
timer clock and I came to this scene
between Tom Cruise and Jack Nicholson
between Jessup and being questioned by
by our hero and I couldn't resist I
couldn't stop watching it is so
compelling so it's just it's to me just
one of the great scenes and any scene
that could come out with a line like you
can't handle the truth that everybody in
the world now recognizes that's that's
pretty good screen lighting so anyway
all that's left in the climax is for
everything to play itself out it's for
him it's for this character who's now
found the courage to move fully into his
essence to live fully in this terrifying
but true state it's he's living his
truth that he does have the potential to
be a great lawyer and he's willing to
put everything on the line for it and
since he's found that courage the rule
storytelling rule is he must win he must
win the case so he comes up against
Jessup he plays against Joseph's own ego
and his his own sort of identity that he
won't be able to leave and he gets him
to admit I ordered the Corvette and that
moment when he says that and we know the
trial is essentially over that's the
climax now there is one beat left and we
have to get the verdict that's given but
it's almost like an after effect because
the main thing we want to know is does
he does he get his clients off of the
hook for murder and and overcome the
nemesis who's trying to stop him because
he's the real villain of the piece
now when the verdict is delivered I
think for the sake of not giving it to
Rosie and everything in a neat bow
ending they get acquitted of the murder
they still get court-martialed herb or
not court-martial delivered is when
you're sent out of the Marine Corps out
of the service because of what they did
but then he passes on his wisdom to them
because now we've moved into the final
stage what I call the aftermath we need
to see the new life the hero is living
now that he has now that he's made this
journey now that he's found the courage
to transform now that he's accomplished
his goal and so what we see is after
they take Joseph away and the verdict is
delivered he goes to Dawson and Downey
says you don't need to wear a uniform to
have a code and to find honor but he's
also saying is you gave me that you
taught me to have a code you taught me
to be honored because his code is the
law he says at one point in the movie I
know the law and that's right before
he's going to go go fully defending me
and Stage five so he knows the law and
then when they're getting ready to leave
Dawson says attention there's an officer
in the room and he salutes him and he
refused to salute him earlier in the
movie when he was fully in his identity
but now that he's in he's in his essence
he is recognized by this other soldier
by this marine rather as someone who has
a code and is deserving of this respect
and so he gets a salute and then they
leave and then the final thing is him
saying so this is what a courtroom looks
like and then he leaves and we know he's
going to go on to have the rewards of
doing this and one of the key things
also to notice about this scene is not
only are Downey and dawson helped but
the law has been served because Jessup
is gone and and there's something about
everything is in a better place than it
was before and this is one of the things
that you want to show in the aftermath
that the hero's courage not only
benefits him but benefits those around
him as well and by implication
the audience as well because it is my
belief that when we empathize with the
character who's able to transform and
find that kind of courage because we are
we've become that character
subconsciously it means we'd had the
experience of being courageous we've had
the experience of living our truth we've
had the experience of showing that kind
of bravery and having a little piece of
that transformation and I think that's
one of the great things we take away
from great stories is we take away an
understanding and experience of courage
and we can put that into our lives and
maybe just be a little bit more
courageous in our own lives in facing
our own obstacles and overcoming our own
identities to live our truth as well
you